[Musica]
l'apparenza inganna
quante volte abbiamo sentito dire la
frase la realtà non è sempre come ci
appare facciamo un esempio guardate gli
uomini che sono le mie spalle
il primo quello sulla sinistra lo
conoscono in pochi
quello sulla destra lo conosciamo sì o
no
sì lo conosciamo tutti il primo sempre
quello a sinistra sembra molto serio
molto compassato l'altro non tanto è
direi non tanto
eppure l'altro che albert einstein colui
che ha scoperto tante di quelle cose che
dopo ne ritroveremo alcune deve molto
moltissimo a quello che alla sua
sinistra perché il primo max planck è
colui che ha scoperto i quanti di
energia grazie alla scoperta dei quanti
di energia albert einstein ha scoperto i
quanti della radiazione elettromagnetica
quindi sono entrambi i panni della
teoria della meccanica quantistica sono
coloro i quali mi sono ispirato io per
questa idea che vi proporrò oggi che
mette assieme la meccanica quantistica
le vibrazioni meccaniche e il cervello e
in quanto a apparenza e certe volte devo
dire la verità che le apparenze ci
condizionano fin troppo anche a me
capita quando mi presento e mi chiedono
che cosa fa io rispondo faccio il fisico
e tutti mi dicono a si vede che ce l'ha
è un bel fisico
beato te che fai educazione fisica tutti
i giorni ti mantiene in forma e io dico
no non è proprio così
quello di cui io mi occupo in questo
momento lo vedremo tra poco altra
piccola domanda sulla realtà
el'apparenza che cosa vedete qui potete
rispondere non è vietato
è un ponte sì o no e cosa c'è di più
diciamo nel nostro immaginario solido di
più resistente di un ponte che fa
passare milioni di macchine ogni anno
questo ponte si chiama tacoma narro
bridge ed è talmente solido che
che è venuto giù in un giorno
era il 7 novembre 1940 quello che vedete
correre sul ponte il professor far con
della washington university che non
riuscivo a credere neanche lui che la
propria creazione stesse per crollare a
causa di un venticello che spirava 40
miglia all'ora
perché è crollato perché molte volte la
realtà cioè quello che noi vediamo ci
sembra indiscutibile ma tutto tutto
quello che noi siamo tutto quello che
noi vediamo in realtà costituito da
elementi da atomi da quanti da
particelle elementi atomi quanti
particelle che devono soddisfare alla
legge di planck quella legge che vedete
davanti a me una legge semplicissima che
dice che ogni elemento ogni atomo ogni
cosa
ha un'energia e avendo una energia
libera l'energia è uguale a una costante
la costante di planck per la frequenza
intrinseca di vibrazione una formula
talmente facile che dovremmo ricordarci
la come quella di albert einstein
quella che vedete alle mie spalle quella
che dice che a quest'ora di sera
l'energia è uguale a latte per caffè al
quadrato
tornando alla legge di planck è invece
quello che va al di là di questo va al
di là della semplice formulazione è il
fatto che noi dentro quella legge
possiamo leggere molto di più possiamo
vedere che ogni elemento ha un proprio
grado di energia ha una propria
vibrazione quindi possiamo interagire
con esso
e se possiamo interagire con esso
possiamo dire che tutto è vibrazione
noi siamo vibrazione questo che un po lo
slogan del mio talk di oggi è
fondamentale perché la vibrazione si
propaga in tantissime maniere per
esempio la vibrazione sonora si propaga
in questo modo comprimendo e rarefacendo
l'aria cioè creando un
penso che possa bastare questo suono che
noi abbiamo sentito adesso non è altro
che una vibrazione meccanica nello
spettro dell'udibile ma la stessa
vibrazione si può avere anche nello
spettro del non udibile o addirittura si
può avere nelle radiazioni
elettromagnetiche quando spiego ai miei
studenti che la radiazione
elettromagnetica e la radiazione
meccaniche non sono poi così differenti
nella loro natura più profonda queste
rimangono perplessi
eppure è così tanto è vero che se tutto
è vibrazione noi siamo vibrazione al
nostro corpo sono associate delle
frequenze di vibrazione che sono quelle
che vedete alle mie spalle
ecco ho messo il rene lì per vedere se
eravate attenti
in realtà lo sapete benissimo che si
trova da un'altra parte
lì ci va il cervello in linea di
principio e sulle frequenze del cervello
bisogna fare una discussione un
pochettino più ampia
il fatto che tutto è vibrazione noi
siamo vibrazione unita al discorso della
meccanica quantistica fa sì che già in
campo elettromagnetico quella che viene
chiamata qe di cioè quanto
elettrodinamica quantistica ci siano
delle sperimentazioni che servono per
far sì che le interazioni tra la
vibrazione elettromagnetica il corpo
umano producano il benessere cioè
aiutino le persone a fare meglio quello
che vedete è il prototipo la prima
macchina si chiama qps 1 ed è una
macchina attualmente utilizzata negli
studi medici al riconoscimento dell'asl
e serve per mandare in vibrazione come
il ponte ma in maniera costruttiva le
nostre cellule e quindi per creare
all'interno della membrana della cellula
nel passaggio degli ioni dispersi questa
macchina funziona talmente bene che sono
stati fatti dei prodotti industriali
prodotti industriali che vengono
distribuiti normalmente come tante altre
macchine
naturalmente la macchina è quella
attorno nella mia idea e allora
sostituire la radiazione
elettromagnetica con la radiazione
meccanica quindi con la vibrazione
meccaniche diventa semplicissimo e
semplice come idea ma non è semplice
come logica perché nel momento in cui i
all attivo devo riuscire ad attivare
all'interno del nostro cervello
all'interno del mio bersaglio tutta una
serie di situazioni
devo andare a colpire esattamente ciò
che all'interno del mio cervello singole
parti o neuroni
eppure si può fare ma se utilizzo questo
tipo di vibrazione se questa vibrazione
meccanica la metto all'interno del mio
cervello e riesco a farlo
esiste la possibilità che questa
radiazione sia effettiva
certo questa radiazione c'è si chiama fu
non è ed è stato scoperto tra le altre
tante cose anche da einstein che come
sempre come abbiamo visto prima se non
ci metteva una lingua non era contento
noi cosa potremmo fare utilizzando la
vibrazione meccanica tanto potremmo
indurre il cervello a ripararsi potremmo
dire uno stato di benessere temporaneo
naturalmente non sono cure naturali ma
ciò che ora è una patologia incurabile
potrebbe nel tempo e con lo studio
essere affrontata da un altro punto di
vista
un altro punto di vista non invasivo e
che tra le altre cose non ha neanche
controindicazioni perché la vibrazione
meccanica non ha controindicazioni
quando agisce sul corpo umano
potremmo per esempio andare a far
produrre alle nostre cellule neuronali
la mielina per curare nel tempo attivare
meccanismi che possono ridurre il
parkinson
analogamente per l'alzheimer
potremmo utilizzarla per fare
stimolazioni neuronali o addirittura
regolazioni ormonali
in una parola sola possiamo utilizzarlo
per il nostro benessere
certo è un approccio innovativo è un
approccio che
va oltre a ciò che noi vediamo
solitamente un approccio che scardina
alcune delle nostre convinzioni semplici
come quella del ponte di prima ma un
approccio che potrebbe nel giro di anche
poco tempo portare a dei risultati
concreti quali sono le logiche che
dobbiamo tenere sotto controllo
da un lato quelle che riguardano lo
studio dell'emissione di queste
vibrazioni meccaniche perché devono
essere fatte prodotta in maniera
puntuale e dall'altro lo studio quindi
investire sulla ricerca delle frequenze
proprie di vibrazione di quegli elementi
del nostro cervello di quegli elementi
del nostro corpo che vogliamo andare a
stimolare fatto ciò però dato che tutto
è vibrazione e noi siamo vibrazione
utilizzando le vibrazioni realmente
potremmo immaginarci un futuro dove
finalmente essere in sintonia con noi
stessi con il nostro corpo e fisicamente
approcciare un benessere che è quello
che noi stessi possiamo procurarci
grazie
[Applauso]